so zum reinkommen gleich die gute
nachricht wir beginnen die sendung mal
nicht mit corona jetzt die schlechte wir
beginnen mit donald trump der falsche
mann am falschen platz zur falschen zeit
ein weißer polizist erstickt mit seinem
knie den schwarzen george freund eine
art moderner lynchmord hunderttausende
gehen auf die straße und stadt einmal zu
versöhnen oder weil sie nicht wenigstens
ein minimum an empathie zu zeigen redet
der psychopath lieber über
militäreinsätze gegen die eigene
bevölkerung ja selbst kollegen sind
fassungslos
der premierminister von kanada
ist egal ist egal er hat halt angst vor
dem atomschlag hätte ich auch selbst in
dieser situation mit nebenbei ja auch
noch 40 millionen arbeitslosen denkt
trump ausschließlich an seinem blöde
wieder fallen
kein wort über systemischen rassismus
stattdessen ließ der mann noch öl ins
feuer und fordert mehr härte gegen
demonstranten
sie nutzen harte vorgehen damit ehren
sie das andenken von george wright diese
antifa alles radikal linke schlechte
menschen man muss ihnen beibringen dass
sie so etwas nicht machen dürfen
genau hart durchgreifen tougher werden
sagt der mann der sich wegen fersensporn
vom vietnamkrieg hat befreien lassen
jetzt wird praktisch nur noch long and
order ist aber gleich bei den
allerersten demos in seinem bunker
geflüchtet ganz viele leute draußen
rufen böse sachen aus dem weg gehen der
polizeichef von houston wenn er sich mal
an seinen obersten dienstherrn warum ist
er nicht präsident militär gegen die
eigene bevölkerung also werden die usa
irgend eine bananenrepublik auf dem weg
zur diktatur willkommen den pool
entenhausen und sein moralischer
tiefpunkt war wirklich der letzte montag
da demonstrieren menschen friedlich am
weißen haus und fremd lässt die
auseinandertreiben von militärpolizei
warum damit er mit seiner entourage
steht übrigens so weiß ist es geben sie
direkt aus einer sendung maischberger
vor der kirche gegenüber ein
fotoshooting mit einer bibel machen kann
nur dafür jesus hätte das bestimmt
gewollt also jedenfalls im neuen
testament nach donald der donald kennt
sich total gut aus in der bibel
alle gleich teil
da sind so viele tolle stellen wir dem
buch besten ist die hier wo jesus
zusammen mit luke skywalker lord
voldemort aus dem tempel jaich der
experte beliebten polizei und tränengas
gegen friedliche demonstranten
schramm cloud bei nixon er hat damals
1968 nach der ermordung von martin
luther king auch behauptet die proteste
werden von kriminellen und kommunisten
unterwandert und jetzt die schlechte
nachricht damit die wahl gewonnen
schramm liebt einfach autokraten und
bald können sie ihnen wirklich aufnehmen
in den club der diktatoren ihr
bewerbungsvideo
[Musik]
ich finde die müssen den nehmen er
weigert sich schlicht über rassismus
auch nur zu diskutieren
die wahrscheinlichkeit von einem
polizisten getötet zu werden ist für
schwarze amerikaner zweieinhalb mal
größer als für weiße sie sind in
gefängnissen deutlich überrepräsentiert
und sterben viel öfter ankurbelt 19
wegen schlechter medizinischer
versorgung
donald trump spricht trotzdem nur noch
zu seiner weißen kleinbürger fanbase ist
er selber rassist also er sagt nein
drecksloch länder
so hat us-präsident trump haiti und
staaten in afrika genannt wenn
nigerianer erst einmal die usa gesehen
haben kehren sie nie mehr in ihre hütten
in afrika zurück alle haitianer haben
aids und als wir einmal durch ein
armenviertel in chicago fuhren er sagte
mir wirklich nur scheiße leben und er
sagte schwartze könnten nicht wählen
weil die zu blöd wäre ja ich höre da
zwischen den zeilen schon indizien für
rassismus das ist eine bewegung in den
usa sich überhaupt black lips meter
nennen muss das sagt doch alles
bitte bringt uns nicht um kaum zu
glauben aber sowas hier gehört in
schwarzen familien zur normalen
kindererziehung in unbewachten habe
nichts mit uns sie verletzten das hier
üben wir zu hause sagt der vater
das ist wirklich herzzerreißend ernster
und um selbstgerechtigkeit vorzubeugen
natürlich gibt es auch in deutschland
rassismus haben in dieser sendung
zuletzt im februar darüber gesprochen
und ich fürchte nicht zum letzten mal
aber was macht aktuell hoffnung für die
usa zum einen die polizisten die sich
gerade mit den demonstranten
solidarisieren wir hier zum beispiel der
polizeichef von new york wichtige geste
vielleicht werden die täter im fall
george wright sogar mal verurteilt
das wäre neu oder und jetzt fange ich
wirklich an zu spinnen donald trump wird
im november nicht wiedergewählt
aktuell liegt einen umfragen hinten wenn
er so eine niederlage dann überhaupt
anerkennt ich behaupte die tramps werden
das weiße haus niemals freiwillig
verlassen
die ketten sich da an garantiert hier
trump vor der letzten wahl
ich werde das ergebnis dieser
historischen wahl völlig akzeptieren
sagte er heute beim wahlkampf in ohio
wenn ich gewinne demokratie ist wenn ich
gewinne
sonst nicht und um diese nennen wir es
mal staatsstreich vorzubereiten
prophylaktisch verbreitet der präsident
gerade täglich lügen zum thema briefwahl
die demokraten würden schreibt dann mit
gefälschten wahl zeit und so ihren sieg
herbei schummeln dabei ist briefwahl in
den usa wirklich sicher um nicht zu
sagen idiotensicher wie dieser clip
beweist er selber hat übrigens das
letzte mal seine stimme per briefwahl
abgegeben
sie ist wenn der skan kann es wirklich
jeder
nebenbei hat eben die anti briefwahl
kampagne sogar einen krieg mit twitter
eingebrockt mit twitter quasi seinem
haussender wo er rund um die uhr 80
millionen follower mit premium bullshit
versorgt jetzt droht er den sogar mit
schließung warum haben sie sich dann
nicht mehr lieb wegen eines tritts von
kramp indem er briefwahl als
substanziell betrügerisch beschreibt
twitter lässt das nicht stehen fügt dem
tweet einen hinweis an
dieser vorwurf sei unbegründet und
verlinkt ihn mit informationen zum thema
briefwahl gott twitter verlinkt echte
informationen das kann ein donald trump
niemals hinnehmen
trump also im krieg mit twitter wir
schalten live vor die konzernzentrale in
san francisco zu ulrich von heesen
errichten
wie wird dieser krieg denn ausgehen ach
was welcher krieg pack schlägt sich pack
verträgt sich trump ohne twitter ist wie
bier ohne alkohol tim und struppi heute
show ohne publikum täglich twitter wird
das niemals durchhalten mit dem
faktencheck warum nicht ist logistisch
nicht zu schaffen der orangen man
twittert von morgens bis abends um da
sämtliche lügen zu finden muss twitter
jetzt sogar eine neue abteilung gründen
hunderte arme schwein lesen den ganzen
tag nur kurzprosa von donald trump das
wünscht man wirklich keinen horror
wissenschaftler haben herausgefunden
dass jetzt kein witz jeder tweet von
donald trump
tötet gehirnzellen die meisten
faktencheck ankündigen am ersten tag
schlimm
abgesehen davon was gibt's da bitte zu
checken natürlich lügt trump es ist
sonst das wussten wir schon kurz nach
amtsübernahme
da sind die ersten 100 tage mit den
behauptungen von donald trump wir
erstellen einen katalog der falschen
aussagen und wie sie sehen hat es bisher
nur drei tage gegeben an denen er keine
unrichtige behauptungen von sich gegeben
hat und an zwei dieser drei tage beim
golfspielen vorschlag
es wäre viel einfacher die tweets von
donald zu markieren in denen er nicht
lügt nach einer zählung waren das sei
2016 genau drei hier original tweets an
tim cook von apple
der knopf am iphone war viel besser als
2 wenn ich auch dann fast schon
philosophisch ich habe noch nie einen
schlanken menschen gesehen der cola
light trinkt und der dritte original tui
bei dem man nicht gelogen hat china da
steht einfach nur china und das stimmt
das land gibt es also ihr fazit einfach
weiter lügen lassen natürlich warum
sollten angestellte von demokratisch
nicht legitimierten konzernen
entscheiden was die wahrheit ist was ist
denn überhaupt war im internet da gibt
es doch auch grauzonen hier beispiel
mein aktuelles kinderfoto das finde ich
also ich 1973 aber es ist deswegen
gelungen
ja ist gelogen wenn ich nicht in einer
demokratie muss man alles vermeiden was
nach zensur riecht alles aushalten was
nicht strafrechtlich relevant ist
inklusive den geistigen dünnschiss von
donald trump außerdem wer ist denn heute
überhaupt noch bei twitter oder facebook
alte leute wir coolen sind längst bei
tik tok
viel geiler guck mal was da alles geht
nicht posten nur noch meine eigene musik
video
ich fühle mich wieder als nichts
glückwunsch ulrich von heesen und und
alles sobald wir eine million abonnenten
liebe liebe liebe fans ich würde mich so
was schon freuen wenn ihr ein abo dallas
auch hier
er würde den gern als unglücklich machen